more Americans and more everybody
including more Indians knew our
philosophy that they had read our epics
that they knew our literature both
ancient and modern because I think that
as such an old civilization we really
have something to share with the world I
wish that as we speak people will use a
phrase out of a well known English
writer like Shakespeare or for instance
for me it's a pleasure to read an
American writer I would wish that people
would have those perspectives as well
which come out of the great indian
epics-- the Mahabharat there are mine
for example if you consider war then if
you are talking about a just war then
you really have to read the Gita which
is you know a the Lord Krishna talking
about the sadness of war but also the
duty that is involved so in order to
know these and to have a more profound
perspective I would wish that people
knew more about our Epix our history and
our modern philosophers in